hey guys my name is Justin did you know
that fairy floss or cotton candy to the
rest of the world was invented by a
dentist also that's apparently a 1.5 bag
limit that a grown adult woman can eat
in one afternoon I found that out
yesterday this intro is going to wear
places let's do news first up it appears
that those who acquired Mass Effect
Andromeda illegally won't be able to
take advantage of all the fancy new
changes in the latest patch thus far
we've been focusing on how the latest
patch has massively improved Andromeda's
unsettling I graphics among other things
but as it happens the update also beefed
up the game's de nouveaux anti-tampering
software pc site dark side of gaming
reported that Andromeda was cracked 10
days after its release however the new
version of the anti pirating software
has never been broken and is also being
used on me automata and rising for and
too dark so pirates who have the game
will be able to keep it but you'll be
stuck with the game's creepy unmoving
eyes so take that criminal scum there's
no telling when the next major uncharted
entry will arrive but that might not
matter as it turns out the upcoming
story expansion the Lost Legacy could be
like 10 hours long just long Naughty
Dog's are niemeyer told IBTimes UK years
ago when we were asked if we were ever
doing a single player expansion for
uncharted we always said well we don't
have the self-discipline to do that if
we tried to do that we create a full
game when we were doing story pictures
we were coming up with a game that would
be over 10 hours long so we suddenly
realized everything we said was true and
we couldn't keep it short not that I
think any of us are complaining about a
lengthy story expansion featuring Nadine
Ross and Chloe freezer but there's the
info for you thanks to an unfortunate
slip up from PlayStation friends we've
got our first look at our watches new
event insurrection a trailer for the
upcoming event leaked via its youtube
channel earlier today and has since been
taken down according to the video
description though at players will
relive one of the key moments in history
of over watch the trailer shows a young
to be on mercy and reinhart decked out
in their snappy blue overwatch uniforms
a young tracer on her first mission
against an omni crow bot horde invading
King's row the video description goes on
to say the new co-op mode King's row
insurrection will allow you to discover
the origins of some of your favorite
heroes with more than 100 new items for
overwatch insurrection including skins
enter screens emotes tags etc it appears
the aforementioned overwatch gang are
all getting crisp blue uniform skins
while McCree Kenji and Widowmaker appear
to be getting edgy Hot Topic style Black
Watch uniforms complete with colored
hair we'll be bringing you all the
overwatch info as it happens so be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss the next
time Genji decides to show a little skin
that is everything I got for you today
do let me know what you thought of
today's stories down in that comment
section and which new overwatch skin is
your favorite I will see you again
tomorrow